Everyone knows that I am a leftist person.
It's not something no,
it's not something I've said before.
And of course I believe in the government's social policies.
I believe in state intervention where it should intervene.
Of course,
in our country we need more
socialism
communist.
It applies a lot of capitalism.
In fact,
we see private enterprise and it has become the second
largest economy in the world and the largest economy in the world.
The United States is considered the model of capitalism.
He is much more socialist than we are.
It has universal health insurance,
assistance for the unemployed,
assistance for those who have lost,
unemployment insurance,
education.
In other words,
countries like the United States,
which we can in our ideology consider as capitalists,
are more socialist than we are.
And countries like China,
which our ideology has sold to us as a communist country,
more capitalist than we are.
really the recipe is not capitalism nor is it communism,
but the recipe is a fairer and more equal country and therefore more socialist.
In the case of the Savior.